i'm going to do a very very brief
introduction i'm deborah davis i'm on
the faculty here at yale i'm in the
department of sociology and i'll be the
mediator
i'm going to say very little um
background about the event how it came
to be um and who is on the panel um and
how we plan to go forward for the
discussion because this is very much an
opportunity
for discussion
just quickly meanwhile media company
which is our focal concern um here one
of several is the flagship
is a conglomerate based in hong kong the
flagship daily is ming bao daily which
was established in 1957 by louis cha
it has a official circulation of about a
hundred thousand yet in fact reaches a
much broader audience than that um
through online version and people
forwarding articles from ming bao
in addition to the daily um the
corporation also does mimbal jo khan
which is published once a week and also
yajo jo khan which is also published
once a week it represents a very very
important position in the media
landscape of hong kong
those of you who are here probably have
read it
those of you in the audience who may not
have read it uh well
i think of it uh as sort of a as the
intellectual um
piece in some persons have even said
it's the newspaper of record and have
made
made
and equated it with the new york times
the particular event that brings us here
today is the attack on the
recently dismissed editor-in-chief
that's kevin lau
kevin lau was born and educated in hong
kong he went to shuyong college some of
you may be familiar with and then he
also did graduate work at lse in england
he was a personal assistant to martin
lee and between 1995 and 2007 he was he
wrote editorials for ming bao daily
regularly uh he assumed the editorship
chief he was editor-in-chief in january
2012 and he was dismissed uh january 6th
of this year um they've already had two
subsequent editors since then um but the
event that has brought us i think all to
this room was a violent attack with a
cleaver um in broad daylight on february
26 um
2014. mr lao survived but he has been
severely injured
and is in rehabilitation um so this is
the
brief background which brought us to
this and i want to thank not only the
staff
from ceas and all the staff from luce
which have come together to make it
possible
abby newman is here
and we thank her very much
and also nicholas frisch one of our
graduate students in the m.a program
here who will be going on for his phd
who has also written
for the
ming bao jo khan when he was working in
hong kong and nick's official role today
on the panel would be as a translator
for
very briefly we have four
faculty and uh former staff members who
are here from from yale who are going to
briefly speak to the issue and then
we'll open it to questions
to my right on the very end is
tom kellogg who is at the china law
center and now is the i want to get the
exact title you all have bios with more
detail but for those of you who don't
have the bios in front of you
tom is now the director of the northeast
asia program at the open society
next to tom is professor chandra wu from
som school of management
where he is particular he's in the
department of finance those of you who
know drew's writing know that he is
interested in a broad range of issues um
libel has been something he's written
about and he knows a great deal also
about hong kong's place and in the world
of of global finance
to my left at the end nick is
immediately to my left and
at the end of the table is professor
kong jungkwa
who is professor of chinese in the
yale's department of east asian language
a published poet and writer
his remarks will be in chinese and
nick fresh will translate
our plan is that ask shirley who was i'm
going to now introduce that's our last
presenter who is in speaking to us from
hong kong
and you can see her on the screen and i
hope you can see us
where you are
shirley yam has been working as a
political and financial journalist for
major newspapers in hong kong since the
1980s among them is the south china
morning post and the hong kong economic
times she writes a weekly column for the
post
china's corporate reform has always been
a focus of her interest
since 2010 she has been serving the hong
kong journalists association the city's
only independent reporters union that
campaigns for press freedom and provides
professional training she is currently
the association's vice chairman shirley
was born in hong kong educated in hong
kong mainland china canada the united
states and the united kingdom and has a
masters in politics and world economy
from lse
so we've asked shirley to be the first
to make comments um surely i will try to
at oh i don't you can't see me but we
would like if you could just keep the
initial one to about 10 minutes
for the introductions uh
uh instead of uh
the violence on calvin well who i know
for decades i will bring attention to
the uh
you the intangible violence that hong
kong journalists are saying every day
um
it's a bit difficult to talk about um
press freedom at risk in hong kong
because it's protected by the
the
basic hall and we don't have an official
censorship uh
in hong kong
and and it appears as if we can still uh
as every one of the people will speak to
free to speak their mind
um
but the reality is quite quite different
from from the general preception is
just
yesterday we announced the city's first
press freedom index which stood 49 out
of 100 that is uh
according to a poll done by the hong
kong j.a with the cooperation of the
university of hong kong um and that is
far from a satisfactory score and that
polling was done before the the chopping
of kelvin now and the sec and a second
of another um
critical commentators so that 49 score
has yet to uh reflect uh the the general
uh the profit sentiments uh
caused by kelvin's attack
uh and in fact with the power among the
journalists are even worse i mean the
the score is only 42. and because what
we what journalists are seeing is we've
seen the resonations of respectable
editors the sacking of them banning of
certain academics for uh by certain
newspaper
uh for being too liberals say columnists
were told not to write
politics so that the paper looks tidy or
uh
i know a com
commentary that is saying no will be
twisted to say yes instead this is the
things that we saw
we see every day and
this all this happens be uh against a
backdrop uh where over the years the
ownerships of of our media gradually
transferred from traditional um media
families uh to tycoons or people whose
income source remains really murky i
let let's speak more about the tycoons
because for the tycoons it's interesting
that why would they want you to to own a
newspaper uh i mean most of the papers
in hong kong are not making money anyway
the most profitable one is only about 10
million hong kong dollar
which is somewhat around uh sorry 100
million hong kong dollar which is about
10 million u.s dollar that's a peanuts
for for our tycoons i mean they can
easily get there from their day trade in
the stock market
and
what's interesting is it's not just that
the coons are uh are jumping on the
media bandwagon so we see new players
joining the rank uh despite a shrinking
audience and the competitions from the
from the internet we're going to see a
two
two new tv channels coming up next year
and another brush paper will be launched
uh will be launched in summer so all
this the investment by the detunes and
the any increased numbers in increasing
the numbers of media simply cannot be
explained with the
with
the financial results there is so the
big question is uh it is why say one
explanations will be media is always
about influence it's not about influence
in hong kong
but
that will be a great leverage for them
to have influence in in in in beijing so
therefore it's not the coincidence that
that most of the media owner have some
sort of political appointments or or be
given some grand
medals in
in in mainland and most of them had huge
personal business in in in china and for
this bunch of
of
newspaper media owner is it's not hard
to guess
what would they do as the as the
political tensions between beijing and
hong kong increase and as the new state
leader spells out a tighter control over
hong kong in its
recent reports on hong kong and also as
the occupy central movement
has now set a deadline to this
completion of control not just over the
media but that's hong kong but over hong
kong as well so it is again all this
backdrop that we are seeing that's all
the increased occurrence of
of self-censorships in hong kong so what
we're seeing now in hong kong is um
yes we have an increasing numbers of
newspaper tv and radio stations but with
a reducing diversity
and we are seeing just okay just today
um less than 10 hours ago
more than 20 uh members of the
news management
uh newspapers tv stations and radio they
queue up in beijing to shake hands with
uh with the country's vice chairman who
told them to speak out against the
occupy central movement
and then the result is also the turning
of press freedom into a taboo in the
sense that when when when when i
personally speak to uh
at the phoning program of the radio uh
talking about how the hong kong
journalists association are going to
speak to the
the secondary school students about what
is press freedom
and the host was asking me so you are
brainwashing our kids on you
so that's what we mean by that this is
the situations of of press freedom in
hong kong where
it is not even okay to talk about press
freedom
and that's quite hard to imagine for for
a free society or free economy like hong
kong say i i do understand some of you
may say that um
all the things that i've been talking
about are nowhere compared to their
suppressions in china and and some of
you may even say that since you can
still speak your mind it's not that bad
isn't it
well but to that i would say that i mean
do not compare our situation with our
peers in the mainland compare our
situations with what you are enjoying
now as uh as a member of a free society
and
and to
to a media of the of the world's moral
free economy to call friedman
what we're experiencing is worse enough
thank you very much
surely for the fault without the others
will speak and then for the questions um
that they come at the end and some will
come from this room in which we're
sitting and others will be sent um by
email and i'm just going to repeat that
for those of you in the audience who may
not have it in front of you it is
yale dot hong kong media
gmail.org and that's yale with an
uppercase and hong kong hk is with
uppercase um and when you send in a
question and also for the audience they
should you should identify yourself
your affiliation and then to whom you
wish to address your question so uh next
um professor chandra wu will speak and
thank you
of course um
as an economist uh probably uh you
wonder why i'm
i'm speaking on this panel on press
freedom uh in hong kong
um to me of course you know freedom is
sort of like air
that we usually don't appreciate the
importance of until we don't have it uh
you know when you have been if you have
been to beijing during those uh bad air
quality days then you realize how
important
a good quality air
is
so press freedom is just like that
especially
for hong kong um so
of course uh because uh uh other
colleagues on this panel will address uh
press freedom issues
from other perspectives let me just stay
on the
economic side so this is something
actually i have spent quite a few years
doing research on with some articles
published and still some long papers not
published
almost 10 years or 12 years ago
i started to ask this question
you know is press freedom
economically important
because we realize that
press freedom has always been treated as
a political institution
and not so much an economic institution
from my research
i think even for the u.s economy so
roughly the year 1900
it's sort of like the turning point
before that
press freedom was more important for
political reasons but after that then
for economic reasons
press freedom is equally important
why for hong kong press freedom is
particularly
very critically important
it has to do with at least two
background pieces of
information one is
for the hong kong economy so roughly 88
percent
of the hong kong gdp
it's from the service sector especially
including the financial service sector
so that's a very important
background to keep in mind the second
background is
just over the last few years especially
hong kong has been facing
a lot of competition uh from shanghai
and uh across the border uh from
shenzhen and beijing
because um you know as the chinese
society and chinese economy have been
opening up more and going more in the
financial development direction
so shanghai has always been viewed as a
real threat to
hong kong as a global financial center
so
recently uh at the board forum i also
addressed this question how can how
should hong kong face the competition
uh from shanghai and other mainland uh
cities
in order to keep
hong kong's global financial center
position
so
my of course there are many different
answers to this question um
but my focus has been on the press
freedom and other institutional quality
site so
for hong kong
press freedom is fundamentally important
because
as i said you know 88 of its gdp comes
from the service sector and very
importantly
critically uh from the financial service
sector
uh first let me give you some quick
statistics just to highlight why there
is this connection okay
according to my uh research out of um
107 countries with press freedom ratings
back in 1990
uh recently you know if i divide
the 107 countries into three equal size
country groups according to their press
freedom ratings back in 1990
so those um one third of the countries
that have the highest
press freedom ratings
have the service sector are contributing
on average uh 62 percent to their gdp
whereas at the other end the non-press
freedom uh countries then the service
sector share uh in their gdp uh on
average is about 48 percent uh so the
middle countries indeed have
their
service sector share line in the middle
okay
and then on the financial market side if
i use the stock market
to gdp ratio as a metric
then countries with
free uh
free press um
have much better developed stock markets
uh than countries that do not have uh
press freedom so i don't need to bother
you with too many uh specific numbers um
but the key point is
because
the service sector
trades intangibles
whereas manufacturing mining and
agriculture
all
produce and trade tangible goods
so when you have
intangibles being
traded
first you have to know how to price them
right and secondly you have to know
whether you are being
cheated or not whether you can trust the
information provided
by the producers and sellers and so on
so this is why
uh
in in the case of china you know when
everyone knows there's no real press
freedom china can still develop
the chinese economy over the last 35
years or so
uh partly because um you know when what
what china makes for the most part right
are those tangible things
then the buyers and sellers do not have
to rely on informational institutions or
newspapers to
evaluate the quality and the
truthfulness
of the products and so on so you can
actually do some extra work uh just like
when you buy a car right you bring your
friend who is a mechanic who can tell
you whether the car is good uh all that
i don't need to be an expert oh oh
you don't need to rely on the
information being disclosed by the
seller or the manufacturer you can do
your own
homework
um but that's a luxury you can have when
you buy and sell or make
tangible goods but when what is bought
and traded right is a financial claim uh
it used to be of course uh you know
stock certificates were in paper form uh
you could get something delivered
physically in a paper form uh to
say state that you are a shareholder in
the in company xyz
but today you don't even get
a paper stock certificate or paper
financial contract
so when what is being treated
is totally intangible so information
the quantity of information and the
quality and truthfulness of information
become very important of course the
unbiasedness
it also becomes very important so this
is why not surprisingly
for financial market development and
more generally for services
the free flow of information
is fundamentally important so it's no
surprise that
for hong kong
the you know after adjusting for income
levels and many other things press
freedom
still stands out as one of the most
important uh determinants or drivers
of a financial market development
so
of course i you know if you're
interested i can show you my very
rigorous econometric or statistical uh
regression analysis uh to get down to
whether you know press freedom and press
freedom is just a proxy for something
else but i can tell you uh especially
for an economy like hong kong
when everyone's
or at least 88
of the employment comes from the service
sector and when people's livelihood in
hong kong depends so much on the service
sector so press freedom is not only
important
for political reasons but more
importantly for employment
and livelihood reasons
thank you very much
my subject today is the chinese
communist party's use and erosion of
hong kong's freedoms when i think of
hong kong the first thing that comes to
mind is two personality types the double
double-crossing secret agent and the
kept woman with multiple uh sugar
daddies
uh the former sells intelligence to
multiple bosses and the latter gives
favors to various patrons
well
why do i use this analogy for hong kong
everyone knows the spec of land was
ceded to britain after the opium war in
1840 and it is a truism in china that
this was a great national disgrace
but for this speck of land itself it
achieved the freedom that comes from
being abandoned and sold out
foreign
after that time the english established
companies banks churches newspapers
courts police and a great number of
institutions that did not exist in the
old china which became part of hong
kong's unique social and cultural
ecology in this dense communities
intermingling of western and chinese
influences chinese traditional folk
society and western civil society could
move towards an organic
foreign
hong kong people before the handover
found themselves not being proper
citizens of the uk and after the
handover found themselves not being
proper citizens of the prc
um their colonial history earned them an
exemption from the one party system
after the handover uh and their unique
experience of british imperialism
and oppression under it gave a feeling
of aloofness from mainland chinese
hong kongers lack of a more specific
national identity uh made their society
very tolerant and tolerant and able to
absorb others cultures
this provided a unique opportunity to
shelter
disreputable people but also uh
play host to those with a
uh uh talent um
unrecognized talent like a a hidden
dragon um
and uh
people from all walks of life could find
a place for themselves in hong kong
leftist and righteous
there were many pro-communist papers uh
there were beijing skeptical papers
most famously there's ming pao
besides the ming pao daily newspaper
that had a very good network of
correspondence inside china during major
events like the great league four the
cultural revolution uh 1989
ming pao provided an important platform
for intellectuals in its monthly
magazine uh and also published
my own book his book
um
uh in their publishing house confessions
and
in hong kong's freedoms we should
discuss the basis of those freedoms um
including aspects given by the british
judicial independence the policy of hong
kong people administering hong kong uh
free trade
and the rights of free speech um the
special situation of the colony uh and
lacking this particular national
identity uh gave it a neutrality but
these freedoms were also open to abuse
and
exploitation by
not just multinational companies or
investors
or
cultural brokers
but also
gangster mafia societies
this is something the communist party
has always taken full advantage
of
for the communist party hong kong meant
different things in different times
before 1949 hong kong was a safe haven
underground base of operations in the
civil war against the nationalist party
a place to fundraise a place to
a way station for weapons and materiel
trading
uh for example the hua run corporation
the china resources corporation uh
that's recently been in the media uh due
to the songlin scandal
was a communist party underground front
before 1949
and uh it uh was important in building
the party's strength during the civil
war
um the party engaged in many activities
in hong kong that were only possible in
hong kong as opposed to the mainland or
taiwan
um
and they early on established a good
network of agents in the city um that
planted the uh seeds of the future
erosion of hong kong's freedoms even
while taking advantage of them
after liberation
1949 to 1997 was also a key stage
um
it's not that china was militarily
unable to retake hong kong um but in
fact they preferred not to uh instead
the party preferred to consolidate its
own domestic power um more than make a
nominal play for protecting national
sovereignty
especially during the cold war hong kong
was the communist party's
gang plank or drawbridge to the free
world
a convenient for ideological work a
place to connect or with or purchase
every kind of influence
and so we could think of hong kong as
being mortgaged to the british
temporarily
for example the xinhua new china news
agency uh hong kong branch uh which is
just next to the uh the race racetrack
the gambling center in happy valley in
hong kong
um
operated under the speech protections
for ideological work um and hong kong
was a the optimal vector for uh party
propaganda towards the outside
foreign
after liberation in 1949 the communist
party continued to exploit hong kong's
freedoms while also using its own
mechanisms of authoritarianism to target
hong kong
with subversion activities uh there was
an incident in the early 1950s where six
hong kong editors were uh and reporters
were arrested in guangzhou just north of
hong kong in the mainland um they were
uh charged uh and convicted as cultural
spies and shot on the same day
means
uh from 49 to 97 the party's other
threat to hong kongers was its ability
to stir up patriotic sentiment
in some cases using the laboring classes
legitimate grievances
it would to promote its ideology um
there was cultural revolution violence
in hong kong some red guards wanted to
liberate hong kong uh there was a
commercial radio host named lambun um
who had criticized uh
local activist violence uh he was killed
burned to death in his car by local uh
communist sympathizers um the
editor-in-chief of ming pao at that time
louis cha
was number two on the hit list because
of his critical
um as the struggle became more intense
between leftists and righteous hong
kongers own legitimate struggles against
uh unjust aspects of british colonial
rule became manipulated by the communist
party
roberto
kong and love the country attitude that
allowed them to be affectionate towards
the mainland authorities after 1997's
handover loving hong kong and loving the
country began to diverge
their previous patriotic feelings were
more of a rejection of the british um
the uh afterwards the central liaison
office
has been of beijing has been a divisive
presence in hong kong exercising in
formal influence over the government
from the mafia underworld to the
legislative council
it uses preferential business treatment
political honors like appointments to
the people's political consultative
conference access to power um and also
hong kong has become a place where the
uh wealthy children of high-ranking
party members do a lot of business and
occupy strategic sectors
of hong kong street press is also
suffocating it
the party's greatest asset currently is
enormous financial muscle all over the
world
towards hong kong media they apply the
method of offering financial and
reputational
incentives first to soften up media
bosses
encouraging them to self-censor
implicitly
if they cannot be bought
then there are other types of pressure
that raised to intimidation or even
violence
the recent attack on kevin lau has all
um
we can't necessarily believe promises
that are made to us uh about by the
communist party
um we should not have any illusions the
sunflower movement in taipei of the
students occupying the legislature is a
good model for hong kongers
after all the power of free media does
have its limits hong kong's people
should take advantage of their still
excellent media freedoms mobilize
popular protest
action in the streets like occupy
central must be united with action
inside the legislative council to expand
the voice and reach of democracy in hong
kong
and finally turn hong kong's government
from one that is
that can be manipulated by beijing
into one that truly represents hong kong
people through the universal uh suffrage
of one one person one vote thank you
very much
so our last comment
yes
um our last commentator will be uh tom
kellogg and then we'll open the florida
questions
uh thanks for this opportunity to speak
here today i realized i made a huge
mistake in trying to follow kang
jong-woh
in terms of his remarks and i i love
hearing him through nick's excellent
translation because then i get to
experience it twice
and experience the richness of it uh
sort of in double time i love
the metaphor of hong kong as a wayward
mistress who experiences the freedom of
abandonment
it's a very very interesting way to
think of hong kong and i would argue
that
over the past few years post 1997 that
in many ways beijing has tried to treat
hong kong and the people of hong kong as
sort of a naughty child
that needs to be disciplined in order to
understand
what is in fact
for its own good father knows best
as it were
and i'm going to argue through the
course of my remarks that this is
in fact the wrong approach for beijing
to take for a whole host of reasons now
i should also uh apologize to nick
because he invited me up here to talk
about the role of law
uh in uh hong kong uh and
in protecting media freedom in hong kong
and i have to apologize because my own
view is that the role of law is
relatively limited in terms of what it
can do
to address
the current crisis and i do think that's
the right word the current crisis in
terms of
free expression and media freedom in
hong kong obviously
miss yam laid out some of the
difficulties that the hong kong media
are facing and the fact that
hong kong journalists themselves
are scoring the media freedom
environment very low speaks volumes to
the current uh situation
uh
let me just say a word or two about the
political dynamics that were
that i think have led us to this
moment
because i do think they illustrate
hopefully a way out
i think you can trace the
current
difficulties to
2012 or so when
the central authorities in beijing felt
as though the situation were starting to
get a little bit out of hand it was in
the fall of 2012 that you had the
hong kong government
lose
in its efforts to push patriotic
education
uh
it's no secret that the hong kong
government was
nudged in this effort by the central
government
in beijing and its failure
to be able to revise uh uh hong kong the
content of hong kong uh education uh was
seen as a very significant blow uh uh to
beijing and its interest in
hong kong
against that backdrop
happening at the same time you have
a
increasing friction among the people of
hong kong and mainlanders traveling to
hong kong you have
fairly and perhaps in most cases
unfairly uh
mainlanders being blamed for certain uh
social political and economic dynamics
not least of which are skyrocketing
housing prices prices in hong kong
and again as someone who has many
friends living in hong kong i
have intimate knowledge of the real
estate market in hong kong it is
extremely bad
worse than new york i think it's fair
uh
to say uh and
you know the market pressures that were
brought to bear by
those mainlanders trying to buy
apartments in hong kong is a real
phenomenon that has been politicized uh
without doubt
in fact there was an incident
just
yesterday
in which a
mainland family was shopping i think in
tst
and engaged in some behavior that was
considered
anti-social of the sort that cannot be
discussed in an august forum at yale
university
and so they were surrounded by irate uh
hong kongers who were demanding
that action be taken and eventually the
police were called in
and
escorted these people
away that kind of social tension
i submit to you
is
unprecedented at least
fundamentally different from the kind of
attitude that you would see in the
immediate aftermath of the handover in
1997.
so those
social and political dynamics led
beijing to reshuffle
their
liaison office
in hong kong
and to place it more directly under the
control of the senior leadership
in
beijing obviously signaling that they
were going to take over
and make sure that
things were run properly
from here on out if hong kong is the
naughty child then the liaison office as
of late 2012 was the nanny who was not
getting the job done
right and everyone knows what happens to
a bad nanny
she or he is summarily fired and ascent
packing which is what happened to the
prior liaison office director who i now
who i believe is now a party secretary
in gansu ask yourself if you'd rather
live in gansu or hong kong i think we
all know the answer to that question
um and unfortunately uh
many of the
incidents that some of the uh
prior speakers mentioned
i think stem from the decision at that
time to take a harder line
on the situation in hong kong uh not
limited to media but certainly media
first and foremost it was the opinion of
some in beijing that uh the patriarch
patriotic education push
lost because the hong kong media misled
quote unquote the people of hong kong
into misunderstanding the importance and
the benefits of
patriotic
education so this issue had to be
addressed and you had a series of
incidents most of which i think have
already been mentioned so i won't
run through them
again
but let me just talk a little bit about
the different tactics that have been
uh used over the past a
year or two
since that transition in the hong kong
police and liaison office
you have
political pressure being brought to bear
on different newspapers
editors journalists and others in fact
the most recent
uh uh
hong kong journalist association report
on free expression and talk in hong kong
uh documents uh phone calls directly
from the hong kong liaison office to
henry lee the owner of the hong kong
economic
journal uh one of the
tycoons that miss yan was speaking about
he is the son of lee kashing and so for
him 10 million dollars truly is pocket
change
um he was
pressured directly by
the liaison office
to tone down the economic journal's
coverage of the
chief executive elections and according
uh
to the journalists association report
journalists were then told in the months
following to tone down their coverage of
the new chief
executive
another tactic that's being used of
course uh
uh
currying favor
with owners if it's not the stick it's
the carrot
so
as we know a very high percentage of
media owners are members of the
cppcc
uh one of the hardest acronyms in
chinese law and politics
and a precious few are also i believe
members of the npc
um which
is quite prestigious as we all
as we all know
uh uh so this stick effect uh again
plays to
uh
the
attempts by media owners to exert
influence over chinese politics where
it's writ large and they know that if
they
allow their media outlets to report uh
two hard-hitting news on
certain hong kong and mainland issues
that the very influence that they're
attempting to
win through these media outlets will be
lost
uh of course we have the dismissals
and the physical uh attacks uh on uh
journalists and editors and the attack
on
chen ping jimmy lai
kevin lau
and most recently two
hong kong morning news executives
i think all these cases have been
mentioned so i won't go into details on
them but obviously these physical
attacks speak for themselves in terms of
the seriousness of
the
situation
so given this dynamic what to do
i would submit to
all of you that in terms of political
pressure in terms of uh political uh
influence buying through uh cp pcc
uh you can see itself uh appointments is
difficult to combat through legal
measures
and so therefore other measures are
needed having said that law does have
its place
and
i personally feel that we can
justifiably have some degree of
confidence in the courts of hong kong
in terms of vigorously defending free
speech rights
if and when such cases
come
to them but my prediction is that their
role will be limited uh in terms of
responding to this crisis and press
freedom that we're seeing play out uh in
hong kong uh right uh now
the other role uh for law is of course
uh vigorous prosecution of those who are
carrying out these attacks and that is
where uh the hong kong government's uh
record thus far uh is uh rather
disappointing uh as we all know
most of the people who have carried out
these
attacks have not been brought to justice
although arrests have been made in some
of the cases that we are discussing here
today including the kevin
lau case so the hong kong government
could do a better job here has the legal
tools to do a better job
and it should be pushed by uh relevant
voices both in hong kong and in the
international community to do more
having said that i do think the primary
solutions are uh
political uh and social rather than
legal and what do i mean by that uh of
course uh the civil society in hong kong
will have to play the lead role in terms
of pushing
the hong kong government
one to
do what it can to investigate and to
stop attacks before they happen
and to
to stand up to beijing
and say
this kind of activity uh uh bringing uh
uh uh people from guangzhou into hong
kong to attack journalists is simply
unacceptable
and the only
actor that can
play that role vis-a-vis beijing is the
hong kong sar government and there is
more that they could do
there
so that is a key element for those of us
in the international
community
we need to remain seized on hong kong
the situation in china
is obviously very difficult and for
those of us who are
professional china watchers
the goings-on
in beijing and across china take up the
vast majority of our time but now is a
moment in fact to be paying more
attention to
hong kong and to be asking us government
european governments uk government
what they can be doing and what they are
doing
to make sure that they are raising these
issues uh with the chinese
authorities
i'll close just by
restating like a good academic restating
my conclusion which is to say
i do truly believe that a change in
approach is in beijing's own interests
because the time in which uh uh
intimidating intimidation and attempts
to silence people will actually achieve
political victory in hong kong i think
are over
i actually think those times are coming
to an end on the mainland as well but
that is not our topic for discussion
today
and so beijing will not achieve what
seems to be its goal of greater
political influence in hong kong through
the use of these uh extra legal tools
and so it too would benefit uh from
backing off uh from recommitting to a
true high degree of autonomy
for hong kong and
letting
hong kongers
rule uh hong kong
with that i welcome thank you very much
we will now take questions uh from the
floor
and from the email
please identify yourselves and
okay and
and as soon as we have other questions
there or questions one panelists
to others maybe um shirley would you
like to say anything uh towards the
panelists or throw out a question to the
audience
well
my my questions will be
the how the um the u.s
that would be the press freedoms of hong
kong
and
as as i was given the impressions by by
several journalists that uh it's not
really a big deal compared with what's
going on in the mainland but how
actually the the the local i mean the
u.s community ceases see the thing
does anyone want to follow that up or
comment yes in the back
alvin chung nyu school of law um
non-practicing member of the hong kong
bar
um
just to just to follow up on miss yams
comments one of the one of the things
i've encountered in the us um in the
course of my studies here talking to
some china watchers
is the
there's a very strong sense that
absolutely nothing is wrong
and it's very very difficult i find for
us
um hong kongers
people with people with experience of
hong kong we've followed events in hong
kong to
actually impart the message that it's
not all roses it's not
it's not in fact an open economy as the
aei would have you believe it's
controlled by a handful of oligarchs
and it there is actually a very big
problem here so how exactly
do we get the message across would be my
primary question for the panel
i think it goes to you
uh you know this is a very
important
question
and you know i think there are two uh
parts to it uh the first part vis-a-vis
uh the us government i think there is a
uh political and educational uh work uh
to be to be done uh as i think you sort
of hinted at
even among
china watchers in the united states
there is um almost sort of excessive
specialization on certain issues related
to china and in some cases by no means
all
the level of
knowledge in terms of what's going on in
hong kong on a a
day by day week by week year by year
basis can sometimes be quite low
so i think you know the fact that
martin lee
came
to
new york and washington to give talks on
the current situation in hong kong was
hugely helpful and probably more of that
is needed now we know we were talking
before this panel uh about the fact uh
uh that
uh uh there were uh sort of political
attacks uh in some of the project
beijing papers uh on uh martin after he
got back to uh uh hong kong and that is
unfortunately um utterly predictable and
other
pro-democratic politicians will face
similar dynamics if they choose to
engage in the u.s
but such engagement is vitally necessary
both from a political and educational
perspective just briefly on uh
europe and the uk i think both europe
and the uk have
tried at various points in time to wave
a white flag vis-a-vis china and human
rights issues to signal to beijing that
they are no longer going to engage
in any but the most token way on human
rights issues
and that is deeply unfortunate
and if there were ways that
voices from hong kong could
try to convince especially the uk
vis-a-vis
hong kong where it has a special
responsibility for obvious reasons
to rethink this policy i think that
would be hugely helpful
here
let me um also add that uh on the china
side
um
if i have to compare the current
situation to uh
2003 when the article 23 uh debate was
going on
uh probably they
um the situation today is much more
unfriendly uh
towards this kind of discussions by uh
the mainland government
of course back in 2003 it was not easy
but relatively speaking
the political atmosphere was much less
harsh
on descent
than now so so i uh yeah i view
what is uh happening
in hong kong uh more like um a result or
an indication of which way the mainland
politics uh
is going yeah i know this sounds very
general so sorry i cannot be too
specific on this but
uh
foreign
previously 20 or 30 years ago hong kong
had a very rich uh media scene of
magazines that were willing to uh
publish a critical
uh uh commentary on uh what was
happening in mainland china there's a
lot less financial support
for that kind of thing now because it's
not as good business as it used to be
um so uh from the american side um
foundation style support for
um for media projects that are willing
to do this even when it's not profitable
would be worthwhile
okay
um my name's jeff alexander i'm a
sociologist here i'm also doing um
a book on the crisis of journalism in
the west right now
as you know
there's a giant problem in terms of the
digital revolution
causing newspapers to go bankrupt and
almost 40 percent of there's about 40
percent reduction in the number of
journalists employed in the united
states over the last decade
at any rate one
of the questions i have
is
how
hong kong civil society is mobilizing
around this issue
i know that it has the capacity to do
that and
around certain events
i certainly am convinced by the panel
that this is a gigantically important
issue for the future of freedom inside
of hong kong and
for the possibilities of freedom on the
mainland and
so is it that hong kong people aren't
convinced that this is a big issue that
they're concerned more with economic
issues
that they're concerned more with
autonomy per se or how does this fit in
because my view is the us will not save
press freedom in hong kong
it will have to be
the
mobilization
this will have to become
an issue of social movements and
collective consciousness in governments
as well
perhaps i can't i can't have a bill on
that is
the
the pro hong kong project let's put it
this way
there's certainly an increasing
awareness on
on what what they don't know i mean you
used to say you don't know what you
don't know uh
as judging from the the turnout of the
uh
two recent rallies uh
against one against violence the other
one is against press uh the the
tightening of press control i mean it
was really well attended uh
one one had more than six 000 people
attend the other one it's
about close to 20 000 people i mean that
is a significant turnout uh for
events organized by the journalists
associations and but still we we do see
the needs of uh of uh
an increase in in proper awareness in a
sense because you sort of in hong kong
while they they see the press freedom
going down but at the same time they
still they can still enjoy a large
degree of speech freedom they can say
whatever they like on the internet so
for for the moment
i would say
quite a number of people does not feel i
mean how much they has been taken away
from them
and so it's our uh
preparing a mechanism
the self-censorship monitoring mechanism
where we'll be able to tell the topic
what what has been missing and what has
been censored out from from the
newspaper and we do think that's a that
that that's going to help
so
another thing i would add to those
excellent comments is that you're in
hong kong right now you're sort of
facing a perfect storm of
all sorts of political social and
economic issues getting wrapped together
and press freedom is an important part
of it but it's only a part of it
so you have the massive fight which uh
sadly was beyond the scope of this panel
over the uh constitutional reform and
the process for electing the chief uh
executive and obviously beijing is
digging its heels in uh uh on
what it feels like is its bottom line on
that issue
and so that that fight is mobilizing
civil society in all sorts of ways uh
and the media issue plays into that you
also have genuine concern over
uh again uh the marriage between elite
politics and money which is becoming
more and more apparent in part because
of excellent reporting both by western
journalists and by chinese journalists
you had bloomberg which chose to
basically disassemble its award-winning
investigative journalism team uh in part
after they
did a fantastic piece documenting uh uh
where the money is parked for members of
the senior leadership including the
current head xi jinping
and some people think it's no
coincidence that the attack on kevin lau
took place
less than a month after
ming bao took part in the
icij a global investigation on uh where
the assets are being hidden by all sorts
of different shadow companies that are
tied to chinese
leaders so this dynamic is also playing
in as well and is playing into this hong
kong public perception
that the fix is in
and that coming back to
professor chen's remarks that hong kong
is a free and open aei style i love that
reference aei style a yeah
i don't read their stuff regularly so i
forget that
oh sorry the american enterprise
institute uh the the notion that hong
kong was a leading free trader uh uh is
now very quickly wearing away as all of
these uh political economic deals uh
come in to the fore
actually also related to this um
you know probably uh most people have
not paid attention to the possible
connection between
the worsening
media environment
illegal also worsening
political environment in hong kong on
the one hand
and the divester or
the moving out the exit um
by uh you know the richest chinese
billionaire lee kai shin
so he has been selling uh his um
assets uh uh on the on both the mainland
and also in hong kong
and uh reinvesting uh much of his uh
wealth now in western europe uh and also
in the u.s so
so this is um
i don't think this is uh
an accident uh so
so
mr lee has realized that things have
changed on the mainland
and things have changed also uh in hong
kong maybe partly you know as uh
uh mr kellogg mentioned earlier
um the real estate prices in hong kong
have you know hit uh such high
levels but at the same time all the
other
issues
that we are talking about here
are also happening to make him
re-reallocate
how his
multi-multi-billion dollars of
investment capital
um
are divided between uh
hong kong
and mainland china on the one hand and
the developed countries
um i'd like to
add another piece to this um and also
draw everyone's attention to the lead
article in the latest issue of china
review
it's by joseph chang from hong kong and
it the title is let me just give i want
to give it exactly is the emergence of
radical politics in hong kong cause and
impact and it is a superb paper
which documents the growing inequality
in terms of jobs in terms of wages in
terms of the real estate issue and what
this means for people under the age of
30 so that they are deeply engaged in
this occupy
movement and they are many taking
they're taking other steps so i think
that on this question of what's
happening to civil society in china i
mean in hong kong um
a lot is happening and um that doesn't
mean they're going
to be victorious
but i do if you're interested in hong
kong and a really great update i think
chung's piece does a superb job because
he specifically links it to analysis
both by hong kong political scientists
and sociologists but also comparative
politics so what does it mean to be um
mobilizing in a non-elect basically a
non-electoral economy
of polity but this is of course not an
authoritarian polity it's a
capitalist open
non-electoral polity and um
of course that's their own there's a
case of maybe one but i don't know maybe
there are more than one case but this is
the one that's in front of us and so his
charge in this article is partly to um
deal with that challenge how uh existing
work doesn't and then your student uh
miss ku is one of the people that he
talks about so
can you add to that
comment
um how how the the young ones are acting
on that and to answer the questions
about the civil society's uh power uh
actually in hong kong two interesting
cases happened recently one is about the
the uh the national education or
patriarchy education whatever you call
it uh it starts the campaign was
actually
started by
a bunch of
high school
students the whole
incident the whole campaign was somehow
very largely underestimated by the hong
kong press
so it will be very wrong to say that
campaign against that uh that national
education is led by the by the media no
it's led by the civil society i mean
it's them who
who managed to get
tens of thousands of people to
rally or and camp outside the
government headquarters
for
for
more than a week
and in another incidents about the the
protections of all monuments in hong
kong uh
and and also the constructions of a
high-speed railway between hong kong and
and mainland china the press have all
underestimated the public sentiment
against
the the two things and it's all led by
the civil society and in the end the
press was forced to face reality and
pick up the campaign
uh another important thing to note is
that uh before the
handover in 1997
uh the communist party was very involved
with the uh laboring classes um and was
using that uh as a means to try and uh
subvert the hong kong authorities as
they existed at that time
the post-1997 strategy has been one of
cultivating um
cultivating the very wealthiest
tycoons to try and support the hong kong
government more
against i guess aspects of of civil
society
um and there is i'll translate liberally
here there there is a sense in which uh
hong kong is the um the the canary in
the mine shaft uh for um institutions
elsewhere in the world in the sense that
um the
uh the authorities in the mainland uh
send a lot of
money and attention to
uh wealthy uh
to people in hong kong with influence uh
with a
mind to influencing events as well as
encouraging the migration of uh all
kinds of mainlanders uh which may have
political consequences
and it's something that
this kind of migration and influencing
is not something that would necessarily
be restricted to hong kong at a personal
or a business level
and by way of background i'll add that
there is officially no communist party
in hong kong
um however there are all kinds of ways
to
exert influence
and so for example the current uh chief
executive has had to deny repeatedly
that he is a communist party member
and still many people don't believe him
uh and so
um
the uh
the the people of hong kong who are
concerned with issues like this uh
should uh try to pay close attention to
the ways in which uh they're uh being
influenced
to read the um we do have a question
from oh you can it's from ming bao
itself from a reporter at meanwhile do
you want to read it um
yeah a reporter from ming bao uh manson
kin
um has asked uh if we do maintain press
freedom
in uh hong kong media
uh what is the value for foreigners uh
uh
are foreigners more able to study the
real china from hong kong's i guess
chinese language media
um
and uh in the views of the foreign
community
uh do they make a clear distinction
between the chinese and the hong kong
media
so um i'll just take the fr of course
yes um
that's a simple answer to a
more complicated question but i think
um
people in this room at least are very
very clear that the media of hong kong
is
independent and distinct from what we
would get from china
that doesn't mean there it can't be
influenced from china on what's
published in hong kong but we do presume
these are two different
two different media systems do you think
that's fair nick
why don't you speak first
um just uh did i wholeheartedly agree
and uh thank you mr kim for for writing
in and for your
important question and obviously keep up
the fight at ming ball uh the
it's difficult to
overstate the role that hong kong plays
for china watchers um you know we are
we're all there on a regular basis
talking to uh folks who are based there
and have the political space available
to be thinking about writing about and
talking about hong kong and uh mainland
china in a way that is much more
difficult to do in beijing
so hong kong's role in the role of the
hong kong
media is vitally important certainly
first and foremost for the people of
hong kong but also for those of us
in the united states who are
looking at these issues
as a means to pay the rent and
put food on the table so
may i
add a bit to that is
hong kong as a china watcher not just
because of the the freedom we're
enjoying but in fact i mean i i am
financial journalist let's talk about
what happened in the financial world say
most of the uh the
the influentials in in china conduct
their business through hong kong because
for all sort of reasons
and it's much more easy for the home for
hong kong journalists to have assets to
those information say for example we can
by searching by doing a company search
you can uh
help in locating um uh different uh the
wealth of different inferential people
and that's why mingpao was
invited by icij to to join the
investigation it's because of the access
to the informations and knowledge about
china as well but what really worries us
is uh somehow the the the hong kong
government is trying to to to jeopardize
the hong kong press uh
power in that in in that sense they say
for example they recently they tried to
change the company law which makes it
impossible for for the hong kong press
or in fact any members of the prophet to
to to get to know who who are who who
are the directors of the company
and it's only after wikileaks fights
that that we that they've agreed to to
shout that that law and at the same time
that was done uh the law that the law
that it just proposed was in the name of
of of prophecy and also in the name of
privacy they're introducing uh the
stalking law which will will bar
journalists from from following
anyone
uh
and but at the same time all this was
done in the name of of of privacy but at
the same time they have consistently
refused to introduce an information act
or an archive act which will allow which
will define
how the
government should provide and should
collect and ship and to protect
information about a property which means
uh
for example if that be you you have a
company operating in hong kong and you
want you ask the government for a
particular folder on on debian company
uh what sort of record they have on you
the government can easily come and told
you that oh sorry uh the phone was once
there but this has not been destroyed
your question will be why is it
destroyed oh we don't have an archive
law we don't have a particular policy on
how that sort of folder should be
handled
so it's about how they were taking away
the power of the of the press
well with new law and while refusing to
to to to protect our existing law or to
give us a new empowerment
is there any more questions
um there's another there's another
question from you uh from hong kong from
eunice lamb a writer and columnist
recently hong kong newspapers and
magazines have been cutting back in
circulation and staff which means fewer
news reports how do you feel about that
do you feel that one country two systems
will work as intended many hong kong
citizens fear it isn't
i'll give it a
go always batting lead off on these
questions the uh
you know
i
part of uh
miss lam's question may be related to
the economics of journalism in
hong kong and interestingly i've heard
from some of the
mainland journalists that i know that
the economic picture for
mainland newspapers is also starting
starting to deteriorate
and that may have real repercussions for
the media picture in
china
as
well
obviously sitting here in the united
states we're all very familiar with
difficult economics of
real journalism uh with uh
the i think the figure was given a forty
percent of
uh uh journalism jobs having disappeared
over the last decade that's a shocking
figure
uh one shutters at the notion that uh a
place like uh trenton new jersey with a
rich history of political corruption uh
would not have that many journalists
covering
state politics obviously washington will
always have way too many journalists
than it could possibly use
but many of the other state capitals in
the united states are
facing very real difficulties in this
area and we may see similar dynamics
play out both in china and hong kong and
this is above and beyond uh the very
real political uh dynamics that we are
discussing here today
well the interesting things in hong kong
is that they are not they are not
expecting
increase because
the new team said the new newspapers
that have come up but at the same time
we are seeing advertisements of
of more critical newspaper being pulled
i mean recently uh very telling cases uh
uh of am 730 which is a free tabloid in
in in hong kong it's only a wrong in his
column that
all mainland affiliate corporation pull
the advertisement simultaneously in
november 2013
this is the sort of things we are seeing
for
for uh
for the critical paper or those who
refuse to yield yen this is happening to
them and it's also same thing is also
happening to apple daily
and the result is of them cutting down
the
the number of stocks so
the totally has not dropped but some has
dropped
i think we have time for one more
question either from the floor or from
email
first
if there's none um nick has one that's
come in in chinese
oh um this is another one no you can't
with the same one it's the same oh uh
this is your
question should i read it yeah okay oh
sorry
um we uh have a a uh junior editor from
uh ming pao's culture
uh supplement who's watching from hong
kong
who
has a question for shirley yam
and i perhaps the other panelists
as an experienced reporter
do you feel that the
current level of media freedom in hong
kong
how does it compare
historically is it really at the lowest
level now in your experience
uh
or have there been other i guess dips
and
well that certainly is the is the
the lowest uh that i've experienced in a
sense that now journalists nowadays when
they write certain topics and in
phrasing their wordings they will have
to think about
what not to say and what to say
uh as a simple example being
uh
there is a
an informal survey
on the headlines of hong kong economic
journal
ever since the the famous phone call by
the uh
liaison office official officials in
hong kong which is just mentioned by tom
a very impartial
word which is siweiler that is the name
of our chief executive
it used to appear
about 100 times
in the first half of 2012 of of that
newspaper the hong kong economic journal
it reduced to
about
20 to 30 something in the second half of
2012
and it has
dropped further down to only about 10
in 2013 the first half of 2013.
that is a very
interesting uh indicator on on what's
going on in in in in the paper
why is the the headlines what is the
word see why learn
not appearing i mean given that he's our
chief executive
and
and that's quite telling on what's
what's going on and when you think about
that i mean people love to say that oh
it's it's even worse during the colonial
time but i was thinking about
i'm sure we're still allowed to mention
the governor's name in the headline in
the cornellian time isn't it
um i think
i wanted to thank shirley from
you i hope it's coming through it's
broken up here
we want to thank you for making this
possible having you as the anchor
at the beginning and closing now i think
has made this a particularly special
occasion for us and i want to join hope
the just the panel and the audience to
thank you for staying up till 2 a.m in
the morning
to join us here in new haven so thank
you all for coming but particularly
thank you to shirley yam
all right
you